[Music]
hi I'm Mark Hall with the Alabama
Cooperative Extension system with me
today is Brad Durham Brad is our uh
natural resources advisor for the uh for
Al University and he's located here at
to Tennesse Valley research and
Extension Center and we're going to be
talking about linear irrigation today
linear irrigation Brad that that don't
suit everybody but in some places it's
it's what folks need tell us about
linear linear is just it goes down and
bite down and bite don't Circle it looks
like uh it's the same above ground but
tell us about linear irrigation uh it's
a real good system for any rectangle or
square Fields you have whereas the
center pivots you know goes around in
circles and some of the edges don't get
irrigated don't get irrigation we got a
hose drag system here and you can get a
ditch fed or a hose drag system and
they're very very efficient uh on a
square field and you can cover you know
quite a bit of of acreage so you can set
it up so that you you're irrigating
every square foot every row of that
field is irrigated if it fits in a
linear that's correct where it can go
down and back which a lot of fields do
uh what are the uh uh
disadvantages uh of it compared to say
drip or Center pivot uh a center pivot
you know you can pretty much hit the
button and go a uh linear move system is
more labor intensive we've got to swap
hoses every 500 ft we have to swap hoses
which you know you have to have either a
tractor or a truck and drag a hose to
the next hydrant hook it up um you just
have to look after it more cuz you
really don't want to pull one of those
hydrants out of the ground yeah it's
they're in the ground about 4T and
they're very very hard to dig up and in
your place how long will those hoses
last to me it look like that would be a
weakness of the system getting Dr along
the ground well the hoses this is our
second set of hoses here and the the
irrigation system has been in for about
20 years I believe um so they last a
good 8 to 10 years I would say on
average for water usage would the water
usage for a linear system be the same
per acre as a a center pivot yes sir
same per acre same per acre but crop
wise talk about crops will just a minute
Brad would it make any difference
whether you're growing uh we've got corn
corn and soybeans and cotton under this
year but strawberries uh high value
vegetable crops would it work just the
same on any of them I would assume it
would uh I don't have very much of a
horiculture background I would think it
would work along the same lines you know
we got the drop nozzles you know that're
closer can you get closer to the ground
you know where you don't have a lot more
you know in the hotter parts of the
summer you got a lot of
evaporation um from overhead
irrigation so
anything else I I just drug him out of
the field and said come here and talk to
me about our linear irrigation system
and I appreciate you doing that Brad any
other thoughts on this cuz you're you
seem to be the go-to guy and I see out
there working on that thing all the time
when when it's going when it's hot
weather irrigation is a job that's
correct you know the only other labor
intensive part of the machine is uh the
furah you know we have to keep a fur dug
to guide the system you dig a furah you
know we got GPS Auto Steer tractors can
dig a precise furra and run that machine
the irrigation machine right in a very
precise location you know I I would
think if you didn't have rtk you know
systems that might be a little bit of a
burden you know it could get out of line
and it's got these little sensors on the
uh the furah got it fur Wheels you know
if it gets out of line it'll cut itself
off and cut the water off all that so
it's it's really good system say a
little bit more about that in line I
tell you the truth I hadn't even thought
about that that it's just it's just a
linear it's like a board it's like a 2x4
going over but it's got all these wheels
so if one of them gets off man it could
get twisted around that's correct um now
the newer systems are they have some GPS
driven systems now would that be on
every wheel or just one the those I
believe are just on one
station um you know our ours is in the
middle of the field our F in the middle
of the field most of them are on the
inside right next to the cart as you
know most people call the cart it's
where the motor where all the
operation uh operations are for the
machine thank you Brad I appreciate your
your sharing knowledge with us today
folks if you'd like to look at our other
irrigation videos here's a website that
they're all on there or any other a or
or 4 or homet kind of videos how to how
to skin a catfish all kind of
interesting videos right here at this
link thank you for watching